even as cbs's mom lost one of its
biggest stars the show still pulled off
a season finale viewers can be satisfied
with here's how the characters came
through their darkest times as a
heartwarming sitcom that never gets
cheesy mom is a rare Beast this isn't an
easy trick for a show that often
features multiple AAA meetings per
episode a big part of what keeps the
humor of mom from being hackneyed is the
way it honors the recovery process mom
understands the careful balance of Hope
grit and focus necessary to staying
sober as it turns out substance abuse is
a matter close to the heart of the
show's creative team cast member Kristen
Johnston has reflected on her own
history with addiction as per today and
producer Chuck Laurie has made it clear
how important he believes the show's
messages in our modern world Laurie told
variety women helping women recover from
the seemingly hopeless disease of
alcohol and drug addiction provided this
extraordinary Ensemble of great
actresses in loving each other and
supporting each other they survive not
as individuals the me is overridden by
the we that we encompasses the Stacked
ensemble cast of mom and including Mimi
Kennedy Jamie Presley Beth Hall and
William fichner every episode uses hope
and humor to navigate the lives of women
in recovery and the final season is no
different the show draws to a close by
admitting the struggle is very real but
so are the friends made along the way
while she isn't physically present in
season 8 of mom Christy still has a
relationship with Bonnie throughout it
Bonnie even fondly jokes about Christy
in the moving finale viewers get a sense
that Christy and Bonnie are on good
terms even though Christy is busy at
Georgetown law while this casual
camaraderie might seem typical for a
sitcom it's downright miraculous for the
plunkets I don't like you but we eat
eight meals a week together most of this
shows humor comes from Christy and
Bonnie budding heads the mother-daughter
Duo are an Odd Couple Christie
constantly searches for approval and a
steady path while Bonnie blazes a
self-serving Trail through any and all
situations but Christy's meekness can
easily shift to rage against Bonnie just
like Bonnie's air of confidence can be
rattled by the slightest judgment from
her daughter these leading ladies are a
comedy dream team as well as a vivid
portrait of living and forgiving in
recovery no matter how much progress
either mom makes they can always remind
each other of the consequences of their
chaotic pasts keeps them on their toes
and in check when they aren't screaming
at each other or smuggling maple syrup
across the Canadian border anyway but
when Christy takes the next step in her
healing Journey all the way to law
school she leaves Bonnie to assume her
own new role Den mother
though mom initially focuses on Christy
it ends as an ensemble show led by
Bonnie while Bonnie loves the attention
that comes with being the AAA gang's de
facto leader she doesn't always live the
responsibility it requires this is
evidenced when she lies her way into
booking business for her and Tammy
bullies Marjorie into attending a
slumber party and unintentionally makes
everyone confront something traumatic
from their past and Mock's new sponsee
Rod played by Steve Valentine for not
remembering a passionate weekend they
spent together during his Rockstar days
you don't forget me I forget you but the
ending of mom shows Bonnie is the glue
holding her band of ladies together and
a dauntless Crusader season 8 sees her
get a sleazy strip club owner to take
down a 20 year old billboard of Christy
spur her ADHD therapist into asking out
an old crush and throw out her roast of
Marjorie in favor of a heartfelt speech
when Bonnie isn't terrifying Adam and
the gals with her wrath she's helping
them stay on track and grow
Allison Janney is one of the finest
actors of our time known for her work on
The West Wing I Tonya and 10 Things I
Hate About You she won two Emmys for her
performance on mom Jenny can pull off
heart-wrenching moments of vulnerability
and slapstick silliness and on Mom both
are often required in lightning quick
scenes it's only appropriate then that
her finale co-star is another Powerhouse
performer Melanie lynskey the Mom finale
features the Yellow Jacket Star as
Shannon Shannon is brand new to recovery
and mistrustful of Bonnie's Shiny Happy
AA gang who are in particularly Smiley
form at the start of the episode when
Bonnie clocks that Shannon definitely
isn't feeling it she chases after her
through the rain ruining her new Suede
Shoes in the process this sacrifice
isn't typical of the old Bonnie but we
get the sense that it might be what the
new and improved version is all about
Bonnie ultimately convinces Shannon to
get coffee with the gang what is it with
you people in coffee
it's the only drug we have left so we
abuse it these evenly matched actresses
set a strong and poetic tone for the end
of the series and create a final
showdown between a stand-in mother and
daughter and life possibly changing in
five four don't do that voice Roger that
Bonnie sees a lot of herself in Shannon
especially her bad attitude and sense of
being marked for failure while we've
seen Bonnie try to play the hero before
this time she manages to put her ego
aside and calmly tell Shannon she can
call anytime she's tempted to use just
like the old Bonnie Shannon is convinced
she doesn't need or deserve real help
and brushes the offer off but later she
comes begging for Aid just as Bonnie
stressed by news of Adam's cancer
diagnosis struggles to give it Bonnie is
rattled and becomes even more so and
Jill reveals she and Andy are getting
married right away and want Bonnie to
attend and then Shannon's mom chases
Shannon through a window when Bonnie
can't get a hold of Shannon a bit forms
in her stomach has Shannon met the same
fate as Jody chaos Reigns the exact kind
that would have driven the old Bonnie to
drink we've seen old Bonnie relapse
before but this time she doesn't instead
she works hard to support Shannon and
Adam Bonnie ends up pulling some strings
to get the brawling Jolene and Shannon
contained at Jill and Andy's courthouse
wedding and their first mother-daughter
AAA meeting when Bonnie addresses the
room with her moving final share we see
an echo of her and Christy and Shannon
and Jolie this makes it clear how far
she's come
while the AAA meetings of moms see their
fair share of guest stars Marjorie is on
the show from episode 1. Mimi Kennedy
portrays The Eccentric hippie with a
nuanced mix of tenderness and tenacity
Marjorie is more than her love of cats
and velor tracksuits she's struggled
with addiction feelings of failure and
motherhood but with Bonnie and the Gang
by her side she gets a second chance mom
celebrates marjorie's long road to
reconnection with her son in the season
8 episode a community hero and a wide
turn Marjorie is nominated for a
leadership award and soon discovers her
formerly estranged son nominated her
they share a touching full circle moment
which is made even more satisfying by
the fact that Marjorie misses the awards
ceremony to provide support to a
pregnant Jill mom also delivers another
poignant moment between Marjorie and
sponsy Bonnie in the series finale my
kind of people and the big to do while
Bonnie often makes cracks about Marjorie
in the same breath as asking her for
help and the finale she's as
straightforward as we've ever seen her
she reaches out in a time of need and
Marjorie advises Bonnie that all she can
do is the next right to action Lee
leaving the audience with a powerful
final message
comedy Legend Kristen Johnston plays
Tammy Bonnie's friend and business
partner at first blush you'd never guess
Tammy held up a restaurant on Cops eat
free night back when she was using Tammy
starts her journey on Mom searching for
a family that won't fracture her own
father murdered her mother leaving Tammy
to bounce around the foster care system
she spent some formative years with
Bonnie and a few years in prison but by
season 8 of mom she's a far cry from the
person she once was she has made amends
with the steakhouse owner and even has a
sweet and handsome limo driver boyfriend
Tammy's story arc sees her learn how to
find Hope and joy without substances and
finally find a family worthy of her
Johnston is familiar with the recovery
process she wrote A Memoir about her
experience called guts the endless
Follies and Tiny triumphs of a giant
disaster she told the New York Post I
love being sober and the recovery
Community it has given me such great
gifts and I count this job on mom as one
of them I really do
no character provides as much extra
comic relief on mom as the unspeakably
rich Jill played by Jamie Presley Jill's
vanity and materialism are matched only
by her desire to prettify her own pain
and her longing to escape her haunted
past Jill blames her perfectionism for
her bad luck and love but in the finale
season of mom she gets more than she
bargained for in that Arena Jill finally
allows herself genuine joy in the series
finale she's lived a lifetime masking
her pain over her mother's death her
trouble conceiving a child her
Bittersweet fostering experience and her
divorce but while she often struggles
with going with the flow of life rather
than trying to control every inch of it
the finale of mom sees her accept
herself and her life as a joyful mess
she marries Andy in a courthouse while
visibly pregnant as two grown women
brawl behind her and she couldn't be
happier Wendy played by Beth Paul is
perhaps the greatest Enigma on Mom and
not all of her Mysteries are unraveled
by the series finale Wendy's
emotionality and Randomness are stronger
than any other characters on the show
earning her many puzzled looks from from
the gang across the AAA meeting room
while it isn't always apparent what's on
Wendy's mind her final season's story
arc sees her get out from under the
shadow of her friends and into her own
light that's right I'm funny weeping
Wendy has learned to regulate her
emotions significantly by the time the
series ends often the show's most
sidelined character Wendy has learned
how to stand on her own two feet by the
finale and help others learn to find the
same footing instead of working herself
to death at the hospital and using
substances to push through Wendy closes
the series as a rock steady leader of
the program while we're used to seeing
Wendy in the background of group shots
our final image of her is a woman who
stands tall behind the AAA Podium she
asks both the room and the audience who
else would like to share Adam lived life
on the wild side until he lost the use
of his legs as Bonnie's new husband he
lives on a different Wild Side Adam is
the straight man to Bonnie's scheming
clown and a Charming challenging
stabilizing Force for all of Bonnie's
lioness qualities her relationship with
Adam's spotlights her tender underbelly
when Bonnie confronts her fear of
Abandonment deep-seated insecurities and
potential for growth it's often because
of Adam's encouragement or because
Bonnie is in the midst of a panic spiral
about his safety William fichner's Pitch
Perfect comic timing and dry as a bone
delivery always sets Bonnie to rights
but when Adam and Bonnie learn of his
cancer diagnosis in the finale Adam is
suddenly the one in need of a
stabilizing Force bunny however shakely
steps up to support Adam In This
climactic Moment she's a rock to her
husband at the doctor's office and a
blunt force object against his doctor's
poor fish tank cleaning standards when
she insists they'll get through this
together the otherwise numb Adam is
truly comforted and she's going to make
sure the team takes whatever the next
right step is over and over again
the ending of mom mirrors its beginning
and re-ups the show's thesis statement
recovery is possible even if relapse is
probable mom proposes that those who
desire Redemption and rebirth through
recovery deserve it and can earn it if
they work for it they don't have to do
it alone either mom finds recovery
within supportive and loving communities
Bonnie delivers a powerful share in the
finale addressing her friends and the
group's dysfunctional new
mother-daughter Duo she admits that
despite the reasons she could have a
drink she doesn't why she offers kind of
like me
laughs
I kind of love me it's a moving
distillation of growth and acceptance
and we see it across the show's beloved
Ensemble though the finale leaves
unanswered questions we know Bonnie's
going to be okay as long as she keeps
working for it with help from her
friends